last but not least today I want to talk
about Bella porsch so Bella porch is a
viral Tik Tok star this woman so I
remember early Tik Tok days when Bella
blew up so this woman had the most viral
Tik Tok of all time the most viewed
video with over 50 million views and it
was so interesting to just see her face
like she found a way to make her face
like move with the m it was kind of cool
and recently I saw a video of her on
call her daddy talking about how her
career actually led her to divorce let's
pull it
up I want to be an artist I want to sing
I want to be like I want to be in the
spotlight like I want to perform and um
I don't think he ever wants to be part
of that sometimes it just it just sucks
cuz you know like you want to do
something for yourself and like a career
but then you love someone and they they
can't handle it so it's just like you
kind of just have to pick right so we
words are important and I wanted to
point out something that she says during
this video that you kind of just have to
pick and you know she goes on I watch
this whole interview she actually goes
on to talk about how he was a really
private person and her becoming a public
figure really just damaged their
relationship and they couldn't handle it
and again you'll you'll see this
tendency for women to and I hear older
women talk about this too I just want to
do something for myself and it's funny
because when men do selfless things
they're a lot less narcissistic with it
and they don't look at it as a burden
they look at it as a duty where when
women tend to do things like for the
family they look at it as a detriment
they they hold resentment to the people
that hold back their decision now I will
say this decision may work out for her
she may end up getting remarried she may
be able to have it all but there are
thousands of women that watch these type
of videos and think they will have the
same outcome as a woman that is worth
millions and millions of dollars that is
born one of the most I I would argue top
20ish per of beauty most women will not
have these outcomes for making selfish
decisions and typically women in her
shoes don't end up having good outcomes
anyway but I just I want to give the
devil's advocate here and here this
woman says she's speaking for so many
women here she is and that's the sad
part she absolutely is speaking for many
women because many most women are
selfish in 2023 most women care more
about themselves and their career than
their family and children and she admits
it there that her career was more
important and she was going to pick
herself and I don't I don't really I'm a
little bit I have a nuanced opinion on
this stuff do what you're going to do at
least she didn't have children okay but
don't complain later don't whine and cry
about the outcomes later you're a man if
he really loves you he'll support you no
matter what oh really what if she wants
to do sex work what if she's putting
their relationship in a compromising
position no matter what really really
and this is this feminist garbage that
we've just been programmed that's been
shoved down our throat that says we can
do everything a man can do and still
have it all the truth of the matter is
everything in life comes with choices
and trade-offs you cannot have
everything Juna pup says she chose her
dreams he can't just be proud of what
she has accomplished right now well at
what cost is the question and you don't
know the ins and outs of the story you
don't know his side of things maybe she
was going out and putting their
relationship in compromising position
maybe he's a private person and didn't
sign up to be a part of that life and
the thing is women will constantly lead
other women down the path of Destruction
so now now you know the question becomes
is the grass greener on the other side
for Bella I really I hope it is I never
wish negativity on people but I will say
in most cases it's not um Bella porch is
talking about here splitting the bill on
a recent date let's pull it
up have you gone on any dates like
what's the vibe yeah um okay I actually
went on a date a few days ago how'd it
go it was weird cuz I he likes me but we
split the bill
hm
what it's interesting because women want
to be modern when it benefits them but
traditional when it doesn't I'm sorry
but why is this girl worth millions and
millions of dollars complaining about
splitting the bill I I mean you know you
wanted to be modern which is fine no
hate but don't complain about the
outcomes later and these guys are
probably thinking this girl's worth I
don't know what she's worth it's but I
would guess upwards of 10 million um
especially what they paying for Tik Tok
brand deals back in the dick guys it was
stupid it was crazy these these people
were making so much money I actually I
met a bunch of the top like ticktockers
back then oh my God it it was so crazy I
met the demilios back in the day which
is like another top Tik Tock family and
it was it was just briefly but it was so
crazy to me to see these like
18-year-old kids you know driving sports
cars having private drivers going out to
these super expensive meal very very
cool actually you know it's like they
want to be you can't have everything you
want to be modern you know take what
comes with it and I think that's
actually the trend we're going to see in
the west because you'll see it in Japan
it's actually super normal to split the
bills there like it it's like not I I've
asked people over there and they say
it's like very normal the women don't
even think much of it I think that's a
trend you're going to see here because
again you know the price of women is
going up and men are kind of getting
sick and tired of paying for something
they don't really get any value out of
so user 885 says you're not supposed to
split the bill hey niika don't date him
again LOL red flag should boy um this is
the etiquette listen up whoever asks for
the date should pay um and I used to I
used to actually have different views on
this like I think um a couple of years
ago I used to say that like men should
pay and I I I my issue with that logic
is like we can't have everything we
either want to be modern or we want to
be traditional and the question question
is if you know paying is a deal breaker
for you or are you the traditional chick
that deserves to be paid for but to be
fair I think most guys to be honest pay
anyway like there just you know most
guys don't really fight it like that